you think you've got a pew pew of the
aliens sure you think they figured out
how to fly to Earth but they don't have
something that can that can help pew pew
you I bet they do but I'll just hold one
of them hostage with my pew pew and then
pew pew and bring me back to Earth pew
pew do you own a pew pew no thinking
about it yeah thinking about it I'm not
anti you getting a pew pew I'm not
anti-pup but I think I'm I'm anti pew
pew abuse and like those who don't know
how to use them and or trained with them
I would say to you if you're gonna get a
pew pew we should go to the shooting
range
I'm I can probably guarantee you I've sh
I've handled more Pew pews than who than
you
what whenever you handled Pew peers when
I went hunting and in the South with
Jace yeah I do who hadn't you have not
shotguns and 22s and Colt 45s did not
handled more people I wouldn't shoot him
with Trevor also in a shooting range you
know I have pp's in my house I do know
you have Pew pews at your house yeah but
when do you go to the range well dude I
I mean you've seen that picture with me
with an AK-47 from high school right
right right right right but that's only
one PPU even I was shooting yeah I
definitely have handled more and I've
been to ranges and you and I should have
a a a shooting contest I was gonna say
pew pew off but that doesn't sound right
yeah we'll peep you off no no
don't say yeah this isn't something we
will have a shooting contest okay